Trascrizione: Ambra Margiotta
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Inizio chiedendovi scusa
perché tutte le C contenute
in questo breve discorso
saranno maltrattate,
come amiamo fare dalle mie parti.
(Risate)
In realtà cerco solo
di essere sciolto e informale,
ma sono agitatissimo.
E questo mi fa sovvenire una domanda.
Non so se sapete perché si dice:
"Me la faccio sotto dalla paura".
Voi pensate che è una cosa,
che io ho scoperto per caso,
che ha a che fare
con la nostra storia ancestrale,
quando noi eravamo bestie della foresta.
Il nostro corpo si preparava al pericolo
scaricando tutti i pesi in eccesso,
per la fuga.
Questo ce lo portiamo dietro ancora oggi.
Io soffro di attacchi di panico,
come purtroppo tantissimi;
e le cose che si dicono
descrivendo la sensazione
sono sempre le stesse:
sudo tantissimo; mi viene l'affanno;
mi batte il cuore; mi sento svenire.
È la stessa cosa.
È come quando il cervello
avverte un pericolo,
e allora prepara il corpo alla fuga:
aumentano i battiti, la sudorazione;
il sangue viene sparato nelle gambe
e per questo abbiamo
la sensazione di svenire.
È questo quello che siamo:
siamo bestie nella foresta.
E lo siamo ancora oggi.
Lo siamo ancora oggi -
o meglio, lo saremmo,
forse è meglio dire così -
perché, fin da pochi mesi
successivi alla nostra nascita,
già la mamma ci dice: "no, questo è cacca,
questo è brutto, questo non si fa".
I maestri, i professori ci danno i voti;
la borsa di studio te la becchi
solo con la lode;
il mister ti schiera in campo
solo se sei bravo;
il bonus produzione a fine mese
solo se lavori bene,
eccetera, eccetera, eccetera.
E qual è il risultato di questo processo?
Il risultato è che ci convincono
che dobbiamo essere sempre al top.
Quindi noi passiamo
dall'istinto allo standard.
Fortunatamente c'è un'occasione
in cui riusciamo a scappare, forse,
da questo meccanismo,
che è il gioco.
Io ho una fissazione con il gioco
fin da quando ero bambino,
e pensavo mi sparisse crescendo;
e invece no, ho 38 anni
e tutt'oggi giocherei di continuo
a tutte le ore, con chiunque,
a qualsiasi cosa.
Tra l'altro in genere sono una schiappa
quindi non lo faccio neanche
per il gusto di vincere.
Solo che, qualche anno fa,
ho avuto l'immensa fortuna
di fare, di un grande gioco,
il mio mestiere.
Io faccio l'improvvisatore teatrale.
L'improvvisazione teatrale
è un processo creativo
grazie al quale noi mettiamo in scena
storie, ambienti, personaggi
che nessuno ha scritto prima.
È un processo collettivo,
quindi si gioca in gruppo
a inventare le cose.
Questi spettacoli hanno vari format:
dipende dalla lunghezza, dalla struttura.
Molti di questi richiamano
una gara sportiva,
come per esempio il match
di improvvisazione teatrale,
che probabilmente ancora in Italia,
oggi, è il più famoso.
Questi spettacoli, dagli anni '90 a oggi,
hanno visto moltiplicare
gli spettatori e anche i praticanti.
Ed è sempre bellissimo ascoltare
il racconto di chi ti dice -
di chi ti racconta la prima volta
in cui ha assistito
ad uno spettacolo di questo tipo.
È come un'apparizione,
è come vedere la vita
che nasce sul momento.
È molto meno nobile di un figlio,
però c'è la scintilla di vita.
E io mi chiedo sempre:
"Come mai uno spettatore è così attratto
da uno spettacolo di improvvisazione?"
Perché lì, sul palco, rivede la bestia.
Rivede quell'uomo che scatta,
che è istintivo, che agisce;
e lo invidia quasi, lo spettatore
si attiva, si elettrizza,
quasi vorrebbe ambire a fare quella cosa,
ma, dall'altro lato, si auto-giudica,
giudicandosi non adatto:
"Io non lo farei mai, questi son pazzi:
io non ho fantasia, non lo potrei fare".
Ancora una volta ci dividiamo
tra azione, istinto e raziocinio,
come se le cose non si potessero unire.
Invece, io oggi vi voglio dire
che tutti improvvisiamo
nella nostra quotidianità, tutti.
Se voi uscite la mattina
per comprare il pane,
il dialogo che sosterrete col fornaio
non ve l'ha scritto nessuno.
E sto parlando di una situazione
quotidiana standard;
ma pensate ad un evento imprevisto,
un piccolo incidente.
Siete ovviamente in grado di sostenere
il dialogo che state vivendo.
E le tecniche dell'improvvisazione
teatrale lavorano, quindi,
sulla fiducia in se stessi,
sulla fiducia nel gruppo,
sull'accettazione delle idee,
sulla loro valorizzazione.
Tutte qualità che secondo me
dovrebbero far parte
del buon essere umano,
non del buon attore.
Per lavorare su queste cose
abbiamo vari strumenti:
uno di questi è dire di sì.
Quasi tutte le scuole
di improvvisazione del mondo
concordano con questa
piccola regola del dire sì.
Allora, per farvela capire meglio,
invece di parlare
facciamo una dimostrazione.
E qui ho bisogno di voi.
Ho bisogno che mi urliate
tutti insieme dei "Sì".
Facciamo una prova, ok?
Conto fino a tre. Uno, due, tre!
Pubblico: Sì!
Perfetto. Allora, volete
che vi racconti una storia?
- Sì!
- Questa storia potrebbe
parlare di un cavaliere?
- Sì!
- Questo cavaliere indossa
un'armatura scintillante?
- Sì!
- E deve salvare una damigella?
E la damigella è presa in ostaggio
da un drago che sputa fuoco?
- Sì!
- Ma il cavaliere ce la fa?
- E vivranno per sempre felici e contenti?
- Sì!
- Perfetto! Bene, grazie, complimenti!
(Applausi)
Abbiamo scritto una storia insieme,
per quanto qualcuno non fosse d'accordo,
(Risate)
ma se vuole può venire qui
a raccontare la sua versione,
non c'è nessun problema.
Prendo spunto da questo "no"
che ho sentito
e vorrei fare lo stesso
esercizio al contrario,
cioè vorrei che ora mi urlaste dei "No".
Ok? Pronti?
Volete che vi racconti una storia?
- No!
- Bene, arrivederci.
(Risate)
Ok, la morale è semplice:
con una serie di sì
io forse vado da qualche parte;
con dei "No" non inizio nemmeno.
Ok? Quello che mi insegna
questa piccola legge
è che io so che in scena
devo portare la mia idea
senza giudicarla, bella o brutta,
perché c'è qualcuno in scena con me
che ne farà la cosa migliore possibile.
E questa cosa la facevamo
tutti da bambini.
Tutti giocavamo a inventare le storie.
Si fa che io ero il cowboy
e tu eri l'indiano
e io ti rincorrevo,
ma poi diventavamo amici?
Tutti lo facevamo,
e nessuno di noi si chiedeva
se questa storia fosse bella o brutta,
originale o banale.
Tutti portavamo il nostro
disegno dall'asilo
e fieramente lo appiccicavamo al frigo,
nonostante probabilmente
facesse abbastanza schifo,
ma per noi era il disegno
fatto per il babbo e per la mamma.
È chiaro?
Vorrei fare un altro esercizio,
però stavolta ho bisogno di un assistente,
qualcuno che mi aiuti,
perché non posso essere da solo.
Quindi se c'è qualcuno dalle prime file
che si alza, volentieri.
Ah ok, perfetto - vedete,
si sta alzando qualcuno.
Allora, intanto introduco
l'esercizio, questa attività -
guarda, là ti danno un microfono credo.
Questo esercizio l'ho visto fare
da Francesco Lancia in televisione.
Francesco Lancia è un bravissimo
improvvisatore romano, e non solo,
che ha portato questo esercizio
in una trasmissione
in cui tentava di applicare
un po' di improvvisazione teatrale
in una scuola.
- Come ti chiami? - Noemi
- Noemi! Piacere.
Allora Noemi, è semplicissimo.
Io mi sono inventato una storia,
ce l'ho qui dentro, ok?
Quello che ti chiedo è semplicemente
di farmi delle domande
a cui io risponderò sì o no
e vediamo se riesci a tirarmela fuori.
- Ok, quindi tu hai
la storia già inventata.
- Esatto. Fammi domande,
io rispondo sì o no.
- Ok. - Vai.
Riguarda persone o animali?
- Scegline una.
- Riguarda persone? - Sì!
- Queste persone sono tutte
dello stesso sesso?
- Sì!
- Queste persone sono giovani?
- No.
(Risate)
- Vai, va. i
- Queste persone sono fuori,
cioè in uno spazio aperto?
- Sì. - Ok
- Io continuo così?
- Vai tranquilla, andiamo un po' avanti.
- Ok. In questo spazio aperto
ci sono alberi?
- Sì! - Una foresta?
(Insieme): Sì! Una foresta!
- In questa foresta ci sono
anche animali, quindi.
- Sì.
- Ok. E ci sono animali grossi?
- No.
(Risate)
- Quindi c'è un gruppo
di persone anziane nel bosco
- Sì!
(Risate)
- E queste persone anziane
guardano i piccoli animali?
- Sì.
(Risate)
- E queste persone
amano i piccoli animali?
- No!
(Risate)
- Quindi sono un gruppo
di anziani, in una foresta,
malintenzionati verso i piccoli animali?
- Sì! Esatto! - Queste persone hanno fame?
- Sì - (Risate) E allora..
Ok. Vabbe', la fine allora
non la diciamo -
- Non lo diciamo il finale!
Rimaniamo così!
Grazie mille Noemi! Grazie.
(Applausi)
Grazie mille!
Grazie!
Noemi, puoi tornare nel mondo
delle persone con troppi capelli.
(Risate)
È semplicissimo: è ovvio
che io ho risposto a caso sì e no.
È ovvio. È ovvio che questa storia
se l'è inventata Noemi.
L'unica cosa che ho fatto io
è stata spostare l'ansia da lei a me.
Se io avessi preso Noemi
e le avessi detto:
"Vieni sul palco e raccontami
una storia di 30 secondi",
probabilmente non lo avrebbe fatto mai.
Magari i più estroversi di voi
forse l'avrebbero fatto,
ma sicuramente se la sarebbero
preparata prima. Ok?
Tutto questo per dire
che l'improvvisazione è una cosa
che fa parte di tutti,
e forse il motivo è anche questo:
dovete sapere che
l'improvvisazione teatrale
non nasce nell'ambito
della ricerca scientifica -
scusate, della ricerca artistica:
non nasce in teatro.
Nasce nell'ambito formativo.
Cioè, ci sono dei pedagogisti
e dei formatori
che in diverse parti del mondo
hanno dovuto mettere a punto
tecniche alternative,
in situazioni di disagio,
per l'apprendimento.
Quindi tecniche che sviluppassero
la creatività, l'empatia,
la reazione a degli stimoli.
È per questo che l'improvvisazione
parla a tantissimi aspetti
dell'esistenza umana.
Ed è per questo che oggi
noi la possiamo applicare
a tantissime situazioni.
Si può lavorare in contesti
di degrado urbano;
si può lavorare per valorizzare
dei beni culturali;
si possono utilizzare tecniche
per l'integrazione
di gruppi di etnie diverse;
si può lavorare nelle scuole
come didattica alternativa;
si può lavorare con gruppi
di qualsiasi tipo:
di manager, di attori,
di sportivi, di scout.
Qualsiasi cosa abbia a che fare
con la relazione umana
può essere potenziato
dall'improvvisazione teatrale.
E pensate: voi che siete qui,
per la maggior parte scienziati,
a quanti ambiti di ricerca potrebbe aprire
nel campo della psicologia,
della psicodinamica dei gruppi,
dell'antropologia,
della sociologia, della linguistica,
di tantissime scienze cognitive.
Nell'attesa che questo accada,
ricordatevi che tutti improvvisiamo:
quindi iscrivetevi a un corso
di improvvisazione teatrale
e riscoprite la vostra bestia.
(Applausi)